the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video well my
friends it looks like we might have
received our final teaser before the
season officially begins on this sunday
or monday for those of you who live
overseas in house of the dragons new
official video fire will reign we
finally see house targaryen's dragons on
full display in all of their glory i
must say all of these dragons do look
incredible but also terrifying at the
same time
imagine being on the other side of these
dragons while they're unleashing their
scorching hot flame it would be horrific
although it would most likely be over
very fast in this new video we get our
first look at several more dragons that
will be featured in this first season of
house of the dragon
now according to showrunner miguel
sapochnick he said we should see about
nine dragons in this first season i
think i spotted at least seven dragons
in the new teaser video alone now
besides seeing all of the new dragons
another thing i really like seeing is
the dragon pit in king's landing in this
shot when we see all of the dragons
flying in the sky we also finally see
just how enormous the dragon pit
actually was it looks like it's nearly
the same size as the red key which is
something i did not realize it's gonna
be very interesting seeing this version
of king's landing when house targaryen
is on the iron throne at the height of
their power it also looks like we get
our first full glimpse of veigar the
largest and oldest living dragon during
the dance of the dragons in this image
here you can see just how massive she
actually is you can even see all of the
scars from 100 battles on her wings if
you look close enough
this will be one of the many dragons i'm
looking forward to seeing during all of
this death and destruction and fire and
blood among house targaryen we also get
our first full glimpse of house
velaryon's incredible strength as well
we finally see some of lord corliss
velaryon's massive fleet most likely
while him and daemon are often the
stepstone starting a kingdom of their
own now i'm assuming most of the battle
scenes and fire breathing dragon scenes
you see will come from these battles
when daemon and lord corliss lead an
army of adventurers and the second sons
we actually get many great shots of
daemon and his dragon karaxis during
this battle alone in fact my favorite
shot from this video is when daemon's
dragon karaxis unleashes a waterfall of
hell on this man standing down below not
only does this look amazing but like i
said earlier it also looks horrifying
imagining what this must feel like i
know i would not want to be on the other
side staring down the barrel of one of
these massive dragons while daemon and
lorcorlus velaryon are off gallivanting
around the seven kingdoms rhaenara and
alison's relationship continues to
dissolve in king's landing i love how
this new video shows rhaenyra and alison
giving each other dirty looks while we
hear someone say the road ahead is
uncertain once again this foreshadows
alison and rhaenyra's fallout and
inevitable fight over who holds the keys
to the kingdom once viserys targaryen is
gone although this new teaser trailer is
only 50 seconds long it does a great job
at setting up this season's biggest
moments and conflicts i actually think
this might be my favorite one out of all
the videos hbo has released so far in
only a few days from now a new era of
game of thrones will begin thanks to
house of the dragon we will all be back
together again when we dive headfirst
into george rr martin's amazing a song
of ice and fire universe
now i don't know about all of you but i
know i've surely missed westeros as
being one of my escapes from reality
after three very long years of waiting
household the dragon is finally here and
i cannot be more excited than i am right
now
make sure you subscribe so you can be
the first to know whenever i release any
of my new videos i will be releasing
several videos each week during the
entire run of the season and beyond make
sure you get ready my friends because on
this sunday this fandom will be back in
full effect as always i want to thank
everyone for stopping by and watching my
video i hope all of you have a great day
i will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you